electro negativity is probably the most
important concept to understand in
organic chemistry we're going to use a
definition that Linus Pauling gives in
his book the nature of the chemical bond
so Linus Pauling says that electron
negativity refers to the power of an
atom in a molecule to attract electrons
to itself so if I look at a molecule I'm
going to compare two atoms in that
molecule I'm going to compare carbon to
oxygen in terms of the electron
negativity and to do that I need to look
over here on the right at the organic
periodic table which shows the elements
most commonly used in organic chemistry
and then in blue it gives us the Pauling
scale for electro negativity so Linus
Pauling actually calculated electro
negativity values for the elements and
put them into the table and that allows
us to compare different elements in
terms of their Electro negativities for
example we are concerned with carbon
which has an electro negativity value of
2.5 and we're going to compare that to
oxygen which has an El negativity value
of 3.5 so oxygen is more electr negative
than carbon and the definition tells us
that if oxygen is more Electro negative
oxygen has a greater power to attract
electrons to itself than carbon does and
so if you think about the electrons in
the Cove valent bonds between carbon and
oxygen that are shared they're shared
unequally because oxygen is more
electronegative oxygen is going to pull
those electrons in red closer to itself
and since electrons are negatively
charged the oxy is going to get a little
bit more negative charge and so it's
going to have what we call a partial
negative charge on it so partial
negative it's partial sign is a
lowercase Greek letter Delta and so the
auction is partially negative it's
pulling the electrons in red closer to
itself another way to show the movement
of those electrons in red closer to the
auction would be this funny Arrow here
so the arrow points in the direction of
the movement of the electrons in Red so
carbon is losing uh some of those
electrons in red carbon is losing a
little bit of electron density carbon is
losing a little bit of negative charge
so carbon used to be neutral but since
it's losing a little bit of negative
charge this carbon will end up being
partially positive like that so the
carbon is partially positive and the
oxygen is partially negative that's a
polarized situation right you have a
little bit of negative charge on one
side a little bit of positive charge on
the other side so it's a it's a still a
calent bond but it's a polarized Co
valent Bond due to the differences in
Electro negativities between those two
atoms let's do a few more examples here
where we show the differences in electr
negativity so if I we're thinking about
a molecule that has two carbons in it
and I'm thinking about what happens to
the electrons in red well for this
example uh each carbon has the same
value for electr negativity right so the
carbon the left has a value of 2.5 the
carbon on the right has a value of 2.5
that's a difference an electro
negativity of zero which means that the
electrons in red aren't going to move to
towards one carbon or towards the other
carbon they're going to stay in the in
the middle they're going to be shared
between those two atoms so this is a
calent bond and there's no polarity
situation created here since there's no
difference in electro negativity so we
call this a non-polar calent
Bond right so this is a
nonpolar
coent Bond like that let's do another
example let's compare carbon to hydrogen
so if I had a molecule and I have a bond
between carbon and hydrogen and I want
to know what happens to the electrons in
red between the carbon and the hydrogen
we've seen that carbon has an electro
negativity value of 2.5 and we go up
here to hydrogen which has a value of
2.1 and so that's difference
of4 so there is a difference in electro
negativity between those two atoms but
it's a very small difference and so most
textbooks would consider consider the
bond between carbon and hydrogen to
still be a non-polar calent Bond all
right let's go ahead and put in the
example we did above right where we
compared the electr negativities of
carbon and oxygen like that when we
looked up the values we saw that carbon
had an electr negativity value of 2.5
and oxygen had a value of 3.5 for a
difference of one and that's enough to
have a polar calent bond right this is a
polar coal Bond
uh between the carbon and the oxygen so
when we think about the electrons in red
the electrons in red are pulled closer
to the oxygen giving the oxygen a
partial negative charge and since
electron density is moving away from the
carbon the carbon gets a partial
positive
charge and so we can see that if if your
difference in electro negativity is one
it's considered to be a polar calent
bond and if your difference in in
electro negativity is 04 that's
considered to be non polar calent bond
so somewhere in between there must be
the difference between non-polar calent
Bond and a polar calent bond and most
textbooks uh will tell you approximately
somewhere in the 0.5 range so if the
difference in electro negativity is
greater than 0.5 you can go ahead and
consider it to be mostly a polar calent
bond if the difference in in electrc
negativity is less than 05 we would
consider that to be a non-polar calent
Bond now I should point out that we're
using the Pauling scale for electro
negativity here and there are several
different scales for electro negativity
so these numbers are are not absolute
these are more these are more relative
differences and it's the relative
difference in in in electro negativity
that we care the most about let's do
another example let's uh let's compare
let's compare oxygen to hydrogen so
let's let's think about what happens to
the electrons between oxygen and
hydrogen so the electrons in red here
all right so we've already seen the
electro negativity values for both of
these atoms oxygen had a value of
3.5 and hydrogen had a value of 2.1 so
that's an electro negativity difference
of 1.4 so this is a polar calent bond
since oxygen is more Electro negative
than hydrogen the electrons in red are
going to move closer to the oxygen so
the oxygen is going to get a partial
negative charge and the hydrogen's going
to get a partial positive charge like
that